a lot of questions remain and we're
going to get to some of them now
pfizer's coronavirus vaccine could be
approved
for use in the u.s by the end of this
week and so we want to bring in admiral
brett juwah who is assistant secretary
for health and human services and he's
helping determine how the vaccine will
be distributed doctor
jarrod good morning to you a lot of
americans are counting on this timeline
of late spring
early summer for most of us to be
vaccinated but we've had two setbacks
recently
one being pfizer itself cutting its
manufacturing goals
from 100 million to 50 million by year's
end and then the second one being this
report
that we apparently did not secure enough
of the vaccine when we had the
opportunity
do either of those reports change this
timeline of late spring early summer
so thank you so much for asking the
question it's good to be on
no none of this changes the timeline for
late spring and early summer
we will be able to vaccinate about 20
million people this month
and another 20 to 25 million in january
and another 20 to 25 million in february
and again there is strong commitments
that we will be able to provide vaccine
for any american who wants it you know
by late spring mid-summer
that's still our commitment and the
numbers i gave you for december january
and february is only assuming
authorization
of the moderna and pfizer vaccines it
does not assume
any other vaccines being authorized and
we certainly are hopeful that that will
happen
does part of the plan for that late
spring early summer somewhat return to
normalcy people get vaccinated does that
depend
on more authorizations beyond the
potential for pfizer and moderna
it does not depend on it again moderna
has a very large capability
to increase manufacturing um and as you
know
we have an option for another 500
million doses from pfizer
but we really are very hopeful that uh
some of the other vaccines will be
available remember some of them have
different cold temperature requirements
uh it's certainly possible that the
johnson and johnson yansen vaccine
that's a one shot regimen
so you don't have to wait that three to
four week period in between
but uh we are very confident that what
we have assuming it gets authorized
remember we're not cutting any corners
here
no corners on safety or efficacy
assuming we have authorizations we will
have enough to vaccinate any american
who wants it you know by the may or june
time frame you mentioned that
you have the option to get more vaccines
from pfizer
but the reporting is that pfizer cannot
guarantee
those vaccines until june because
they've given deals to
other countries on that subject the
president today is going to sign an
executive order prioritizing
americans from where you're sitting what
what effect will that order have
um so from where i'm sitting i i think
it it's uh
it's fair to say that the the vaccines
purchased by
america um we need to use those on
the very highly vulnerable individuals
that we have in our system you
saw the reporting you've reported some
of it even earlier in the intro
our hospital systems are strained our
death rates are going up
and we certainly want the vaccines
procured by america that doesn't mean
uh procured by other countries there are
procurements by other countries like the
uk and
around the world but those procured by
america
should be used for americans who are
vulnerable to save their lives
i think many americans would agree so on
that point does the executive order
change anything and has
have you heard any discussion of say the
defense authorization act
prioritizing the pfizer supply chain
here in the u.s so forcing them to sell
to us
no i'm not aware of any discussions of
that i'm not on the warp speed side but
i'm not aware of any discussions we use
the dpa
all the time on the testing side and and
for supplies
but i've not heard any discussions about
that all right some straight talk
admiral brett jorah thank you very much
thank you thank you